now I am very aware that to come here
and speak about a new museum development
of the scale and ambition of m+ in Hong
Kong now I must also acknowledge the
social unrest that is now our reality it
is a fact that the eyes of the world are
focused on the city and the West is
looking East this time to watch events
as they unfold across four months of
both peaceful and violent protests there
is no question there that we are living
in deeply unsettled times it is intense
the divisions in emerging and hardening
in the city make for an emotionally
exhausting reality over 85% of Hong Kong
does not own a car so the transport
arterioles the Metro the MTR our subway
system are vital avenues to move around
this highly efficient public transport
system is now being severely tested
through weekly confrontations and
disruptions that focus on the MTR and
for a while the airport
I have no crystal ball to be able to
suggest how this situation will resolve
we are living in a very divided city I
do think though that some of the works
in the em+ collections offer a chance to
reflect to pause and see what artists
have made sometimes in earlier years as
a means of providing insight into what
is happening today it is a sort of
creative tool a discursive thought
provoking journey to now currently on
display at the em pub in PLAs Pavilion
is an exhibition titled five artists
sights encountered and the Hong Kong
artist Mei
phones 1989 work she said why me is
being screened May is a founding member
of video Tosh an experimental artist
from space established to support Moving
Image artists with a forum to share
ideas show works build networks Bulow's
both locally and globally slicing
historical footage from colonial era
Hong Kong with images of the 1967 riots
in Hong Kong the work explores
the ambiguity and uncertainties around
identity that the artist felt at the
time of making the work in 1989 thirty
years ago when she made this Hong Kong
was preparing for handover and the push
and pull of that time feels strangely
apt thirty years later in 2019 we opened
this exhibition three days before the
protests began we had no idea that this
was coming and the exhibition was in
planning for eight months before Sampson
Young's we are the world
since 2015 Empress has co-presented
together with the Hong Kong arts
Development Council the Hong Kong's
Pavilion in at the Venice Biennale now
in 2017 Sampson who comes out of new
music and composition was commissioned
by implants to make a new work and he
chose to approach the pavilion via the
cypher of songs for disaster relief
cogitating on the failed utopian Raja
of global disaster relief and that hope
to fund change through releasing pop
songs sung by the likes of Ikon such as
Bob Geldof in we are the world young
worked with the Hong Kong Federation of
trade unions choir and asked them to
vocalize a familiar song it's a kind of
unlearning of what it means to sing it's
a new music technique where the voice
whispers the song you can barely hear we
are the world now looking at the world
today it in me it looking at the work
today and the world today it immediately
suggests an international context you
know we are the world and Hong Kong is
on a fault line one that feels intensely
local but as it goes beyond
currently showing at the Hong Kong
Venice pavilion again we go commissioned
is the work of surely say stakeholders
Hong Kong in Venice her commissioned
work negotiated differences is a new
work it's a sculpture made of singular
pieces of turned wood each piece is
unique often in the shape of an everyday
object a chair leg a tenpin a baseball
bat a rolling pin candelabra each of
these turned wood sculptures is
connected to another using piping joints
that have been made with 3d printing
using the traditional Chinese furniture
making technique of joinery the
sculpture uses no nails
pins or glue rather the work is
connected together through balance a
rhizomatic structure that we use its way
through the veil
spaces of the Venice pavilion the
sculpture negotiated difference can
never be viewed in its entirety from a
single point of view you need to walk
through and around it to see it should
one section come undone the work
collapses and needs to be reassembled
and brought back into its wholeness as
balance